what's hopping some kid says you got
cheese we went cheese yeah I wasn't
consulted in this book Patrick all right
so now that we have so much free time in
our hands we're gonna be trying some of
America's favorite places to grab a
quick bite these places have huge fan
followings which is weird
at furniture and bulk store people love
the food that they're making in the
kitchens there which is kind of
surprising when was the last time you
ate here never I've never you never
you've never had Costco Pizza who have
one slice of pizza one hot dog and
cheese and a twisted churro oh this is
cheap yeah dude under five dollars
it's eight cents under five dollars so
we got eight children a pizza what what
topping some kid says you're gonna cheat
we went cheat Aaron yes I wasn't
consulted in this what the Patrick
cheese is enough you cheese just don't
go to Italy until my there's no I'm
totally okay what kind of you eat your
pizza friend dude bro
[Music]
Stadium dog classic Stadium Doug this is
actually better than a lot of hot dogs
I've had for more money if you are gonna
bring a date to Costco this is how you
got to be eating
don't like it it reminds me of gas
station Pizza and I like gas station
Pizza it does remind me again see maybe
if you had a can top in would be better
I like the pizza it's good one two five
as far as food now get rid of 4.5 I'll
give this taste of curry this is like
okay cheaper questionable foods like
there's other places where I would be
like no there's just good yeah what name
a better place 7-eleven no stop that is
disrespectful to Costco ordering was so
easy and simple and fast I mean just
pull up order stripe your car yeah and
they hand you the food it's really nuts
how they do it here quick experience I
give this experience a fire I give this
parking lot restaurant a four star on
ambience and experience the table had
mustard when we sat down but that's
totally fine because you're just quick
on the go you know the value on this was
insane by less than five dollars for all
the stuff it's a five if I have kids I
will bring in here go inside do my
grocery shopping without them buy them
like twenty dollars worth of food here's
gonna leave your kids out here listen
okay maybe I won't leave a bow give him
the phone first presentation and
ambiance is much better here filled yeah
this is like this rules yeah I love the
wood aesthetic it's much more like homey
kitchen like I want to like sit in my
castle in that grandma made for me we'll
go to town with the classic the Swedish
meatballs Cheers that's really good
yeah that was really nice first
impression this mouth we haven't done a
taste is in a long time huh it's been a
whole month does you have a minute bus
Peter you forgot we're good yeah you
know the good ones yeah mm-hmm
really crunchy and flaky on the outsides
nice you're in a diet right yeah yeah so
this has to be really good in order for
you to really think it's worth breaking
your diet
yeah totally hmm that's good mmm hmm hmm
is good yeah that's good mm-hmm dude a
little nuts on top mmm-hmm I'm into that
food pretty good I'll give it a four
this I will give of our pro/5 as well I
think they're both equally good in
different spectrums of where you want to
give food I just gotta say from the
moment we walked in the ambiance is
definitely an improvement yeah look was
it a little tedious yeah like waiting in
the line going down different stations
not my favorite way to order to be
honest with you but there was one person
in front of us it might be eating at
Disneyland which is a stressful
experience oh yeah for 105 what would
you give IKEA as far as the experience
in the ambiance I would say four and a
half I would give it a five I think it's
a lot cleaner big time it's less loud
because we got in a parking lot
obviously with one plate where are we
spending more than what we spent for
three different options at Costco but
you got protein you got your vegetables
you got a little carb starch there you
know you're getting it's more or less
than well better than ooh yeah I think
in value like this $6.99 this is cool I
think we're value I'll give it a three
and a half three and a half I give it a
four four value the only thing that
would make my value go up as if I got
more like sauces to go with my chicken
tenders even though I do think IKEA food
was a little bit better and that jambe
is was better I think I like Costco
better because it delivered on the
premise of quick and she
yeah and eating in a parking lot I kind
of like that yeah it crushed they were
both really good they look great in with
a hug nothing better than team food when
you're unemployed right
[Music]